this is not a death sentence you played
a big part in springing the leak in the
darkness you realize you helped save my
life the only reason why I'm standing
here today is to use my story to help
others who may suffer from what I suffer
from
I was crushing it on the field going to
Pro Bowls got the biggest contract in
wide-receiver history but off the field
my life was a mess I just didn't have
the skills and the tools to be able to
cope with the things that comes with a
lifestyle that I was throwing in the
lifestyle that I was living he was
associated with some very troubling
incidents early on in his career they
were all kind of based around rage and
so I think people were very cautious and
very leery of him stuff just sitting in
me and carrying his bag of something
else what happened something else right
there boom he seemed to be on that path
of you know being somebody extremely
talented who is never going to be able
to maximize their talent because they
couldn't get out of their own way you
know when you start making these
mistakes on a global platform it forces
you to really either fold or stand up
and deal with it I had to go to McLean
Hospital for three months I was in the
outpatient program and it immediately
transformed my life I was diagnosed with
borderline personality disorder the best
way I can describe it is an emotional
disorder I spent three months breaking
down the Beast Barnes and Noble's became
my locker room those books became my
playbook and every single day I just
said you know until I get this thing
right I'm going to live in this and
figure this thing out Brandon was okay
with sort of humbling himself they just
a mortal human being that was struggling
with a very prominent issue I was
sitting in group I just saw these people
fighting and I was fighting and that's
when I said man people need to hear
these stories
I remember a high school soccer game
towards the end of my sophomore year and
she was all hunkered over on the bench
with her head on her knees not kept
sinking what's wrong with her
something's happening next thing I know
she's walking across the field and my
mom met me down there she just threw her
head on my shoulder sobbing why is this
happening to me why is something in the
way every single time I turn around now
looking back I had had an anxiety attack
it started this like ongoing theft
between my brain and my heart and it was
the beginning of the dark times she went
through therapy for a while she was
diagnosed with generalized anxiety
disorder and depression the thought of
even trying to deal with whatever's
going on inside of me was so daunting it
was just complete and total chaos when
Megan went off to college I was I was
happy and I was concerned because I knew
there were issues but I was happy
because I thought maybe it's a fresh
start in a fresh environment this is the
first time that I've been back to this
apartment since I moved out and it's the
apartment that I attempted suicide in
August 22nd 2013 I just decided I was
like I'm done I'm so tired of trying to
figure this out and not ever being who I
want to be my roommate wasn't home I
went into my bedroom I had a whole bunch
of like miscellaneous cords in the
corner of my room and started doing it
but for some reason for reasons beyond
me I still can't explain it it's like a
kaleidoscope of faces that I love and
things that I actually like doing just
started coming to the forefront of my
mind and I have no idea why those things
chose to overcome all the bad things at
that moment but I stopped my thoughts
when all of this was happening was
please God don't take my daughter don't
let her go we need her here and I want
to tell her again that I love her
there was a lot at stake for Brandon
when he decided to go public I'm making
myself vulnerable and I want it to be
clear that this is the opposite of
damage control here you are a football
player who's admitting that mentally you
have some issues my purpose here today
is to bring awareness to this disorder
that is highly stigmatized I mean
there's a lot of teams despite his
physical talent who could have decided
we can't trust this guy we don't want
someone like that on our team what I
could have lost if I didn't get the help
I needed number one maybe my life now I
wasn't suicidal but if I would have lost
my wife if I lost my career no telling
what would have happened the only reason
why I'm standing here today is to use my
story to help others who may suffer from
what I suffer from by telling my story
someone is going to hear it and be free
this is not a death sentence
someone's going to hear it and have hope
you can live a healthy and effective
life soil in here they potentially save
their life I don't know what's going to
come out of this but
something good is when it happened
there's a whole
can we start again
we start again suicide was on my mind
still those thoughts were still present
up until I happened upon Brandon's video
from 2011 the one sentence I remember
that he said is that I have borderline
personality disorder and really that's
all I needed to hear at that moment
before then I knew he was a football
player but I didn't know that I could
relate to him
we start again
Brandon's courage to go public ignited a
courage inside of me that I didn't know
existed no matter the situation you
still can keep your head up high and
still live life effectively in a way
that you can enjoy and be mindful at the
moment I'm very thankful that Brandon
went public we often say if it touches
one life it's worth it it's cuts Megan's
life but actually it's that's mine and
Penny and her sister Delaney and all of
her family it's touched many many many
lives what I learned is football is my
platform to fulfill my purpose I think
this is my purpose got it we got was we
going to talk for a little bit sometimes
we get caught up in a big picture but
these are the stories that keep you
going that gives you confirmation that
what you're doing is right if you or
anyone you love is struggling with the
mental illness that you or that person
can't understand please call the
National Suicide Prevention lifeline